GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
MAY NINETEENTH ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS SUSPENSE HEARING
ON ASSEMBLY BILLS WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. HERE.
HOLDEN YOUR- BIGELOW. RYAN
CALDERON VIDEO DOLLY DAVIES. MY
FONG VINCE FONG GABRIEL EDUARDO
GARCIA LEVINE BOOK. ROBERT RIVAS
WEBER. WILSON. HEY WE HAVEA
QUORUM. BUT BEFORE WE START WITH
THE SIX HUNDRED AND ONE BILLS ON
SUSPENSE FILE I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
REPUBLICAN STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK AD THEIR SUPPORT. IS MUCH
APPRECIATED I COULD NOT ASK FOR
MORE DEDICATED GROUP OF
PROFESSIONALS TO ASSIST IN THIS
EFFORT. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE STAFF OF THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANT'S
OFFICE THE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PERSONNEL IN THE MANY
OTHERS WHO HELPED ENSURE THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS CONTINUES AS
WE TRANSITION TO A MORE NORMAL.
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU ALL. THEY
ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY VICE CHAIR
FOR HIS COOPERATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADD IT TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR HARD WORK
ON THE BILLS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS THE COMMITTEE HAS
MOVED THE SIX OR ONE BILLS UNDER
CONSIDERATION OF THE SUSPENSE
FILE IT IS NOW TIME TO DISPENSE
WITH THEM. BUT ALSO LIKE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT THE HEARING AGENDA
IS ORGANIZED ALPHABETICALLY BY
AUTHOR. WITH THE NINE BILLS
AUTHORED BY THE ASSEMBLY POLICY
COMMITTEE LISTED AT THE END OF
THE AGENDA. MIA BONTA ODDS NAME
WILL BE CALLED UNDER THE MS NOT
BEES. ASSEMBLY POLICY COMMITTEES
LISTED AT THE END OF THE GENDA
AND ELECTRONIC COPY OF THE
AGENDA IS AVAILABLE ONLINE AT
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHICH IS
LOCATED AT A PRO DOT ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOV. THERE ARE ALSO
LIMITED NUMBER OF HARD COPIES OF
THE AGENDA IN THE HEARING ROOM.
LATER THIS AFTERNOON FOLLOWING
TODAY'S HEARING THE COMMITTEE
WILL POST THE RESULTS OF THE
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING ON THE
SAME WEBSITE. OR DO YOU MISTER
BIGELOW IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO OFFER AT THIS
MOMENT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ARM. I'D LIKE TO ECHO ALL OF
YOUR COMMENTS DODD THERE
THANKING OUR STAFFS IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY PUT UP A
LOT OF LONG. HARD HOURS TO GO
THROUGH IN DETAIL AT AND IT'S
NOT JUST THE COMMITTEE STAFFS ON
BOTH SIDES IT'S R. STABS. UP
BEHIND THE SCENES FOR EACH
MEMBER THAT PUTS IN THE RIGOROUS
HOURS ALONG WITH A MEMBER MAKE
SURE WE'VE GIVEN DUE DILIGENCE
AND A GREAT DEAL OF TIME AND
ATTENTION TO. CONSIDERATION OF
EACH BILL- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO BE RESPECTFUL OF
EVERYONE'S TIME- BUT SOMETIMES
IT'S COMMITTEE TAKES AN EXTRA
BIT OF TIME. BECAUSE THE
THOROUGHNESS THAT STEIN. IBM
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO CONGRATULATE
OUR- NUDE NEW CHAIRMAN ON HIS
EFFORTS AND WHAT HE'S DONE AND
SOME OF THE- VITALITY HE'S
BROUGHT TO THE COMMITTEE SO I
THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN. AND IT'S
BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU. AND WITH
THAT LET US BEGIN. THE FIRST
BILL BEFORE THE COMMITTEE IS AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OCULAR CURRY IS OUR MOTION. THAT
BILL GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION AND SECOND
FOR ALL DO PASS OR DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS ON THE REST. OF
THE SUSPENSE FILE. AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY OCULAR CURRY BROOMRAPE
CONTROL PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
OCULAR CURRY YOUR REDUCTION
PUBLIC WORKS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CLARIFY THE FUELREDUCTION
WORK MUST BE DONE UNDER CONTRACT
. AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
AGHOLOR CURRY MIGRANT EDUCATION
EXTENDED SCHOOL YEAR PROGRAM.
THE PATH.
WHEN I GO BACK IN DECEMBER SAID
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN OCC SIMILAR
OCULAR CURRY I WAS A OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
OKAY AND UNDERSERVED AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN AGUILAR
CURRY YOUR REDUCTION PUBLIC
WORKS WAS TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL. OKAY IT'S ROCK AND ROLL AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN AGHOLOR
CURRY FUEL REDUCTION PUBLIC
WORKS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THE FUEL REDUCTION WORK
MUST BE DONE UNDER CONTRACT. AB
TEAM. OF B. ROLL CALL. EVOGENE
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
GILLER CURRY MIGRANT EDUCATION
EXTENDED SCHOOL YEAR PROGRAM TO
PASS THE ROLL CALL SORRY A ROLL
CALL AB EIGHTEEN OH NINE OCULAR
CURRY NURSING FACILITY RESIDENTS
INFORMED CONSENT TO PASS THE
ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE AGHOLOR CURRIED DISASTER
HOUSING PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN AGHOLOR CURRY WINE
GRAPES SMOKE RESEARCH HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
TWO OCULAR CURRY BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE REPORTS HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY THREE OH
THREE OCULAR CURRY AGAVE SPIRITS
LABELING DO PASS. REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTEEN AGHOLOR CURRY HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE HUMAN PAPA LOW
LOMA VIRUS TO PASS. OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX SECULAR CURRY VOTER
REGISTRATION AND OUTREACH
PROGRAMS HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN NGULAR
CURRY MEDICAL COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. AND FROM A TAURUS DO
PASSED B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT REGULAR
CURRY FOREST BIOMASS WASTE
UTILIZATION PROGRAM TO PASS AS A
MINUTE TO STRIKE SECTIONS TO
ENFORCE STRIKE LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE ADOPTION OF
PIPELINE BY AGO STANDARDS STRIKE
SUNSET EXTENSION FOR THE BIO MAT
PROGRAM AND MAKE OTHER CHANGES.
THAT'S REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY ARAMBULA LABOR
TRAFFICKING UNIT DO PASS A ROLL
CALL. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
ARAMBULA PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AND
STEP THERAPY DO PASSED B. ROLL
CALL AB NINETEEN HUNDRED
ARAMBULA MEDIKAL MAINTENANCE
NEEDS INCOME LEVEL DO PASS A
ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN THIRTY
ARAMBULA MEDIC CAL COMPREHENSIVE
PRENATAL SERVICES DO PASS B.
ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN NINETY
ARAMBULA DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE ARAMBULA MEDIC CAL PREMIUMS
CONTRIBUTIONS AND CO PAYMENTS TO
PASS REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
NINETEEN NINETY NINE ARAMBULA
MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INDIVIDUALS WITH VISION LOSS TO
DO PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
THIRTY ARAMBULA COUNTY OR FRESNO
CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION TO PASS B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY NINETY ARAMBULA CHILD
WELFARE INCENTIVE PAYMENTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE ARAMBULA FRUIT AND
VEGETABLE SUPPLEMENTAL BENEFITS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED ARAMBULA ONLINE JOB
PLATFORM GRANTS HOLDEN COMMITTEE
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE
ARAMBULA PHARMACY DISPENSING
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE LOCK
LOCKABLE VIALS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. A. B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY ARAMBULA EMERGENCY
RESPONSE ADVISORY WORKING GROUP
TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ARAMBULA PRENATAL
PRENATAL AND INFANT CHILDREN
HEALTH EXTREME HE DO PASSED A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
ARAMBULA REHABILITATION SERVICES
FOR PERSONS WITH VISION LOSS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED ARAMBULA FARM TO
HOSPITAL PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
ARAMBULA SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT DO
PASSED B. ROLL CALL AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY ARAMBULA SOCIAL
WORKER TRAINING HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
ARAMBULA MEDICAL COMMUNITY
HEALTH NAVIGATOR PROGRAM DO
PASSED B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR RAMBLE A MEDIC
CAL ALTERNATIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLAN TO PASS B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY EIGHT TEN
ARAMBULA STUDENT ELIGIBILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S TO PASS A ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ARAMBULA
CIVIL SERVICE SUPERVISOR
APPOINTMENTS HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE
ARAMBULA TEMPORARY WATER RIGHTS
TRANSFERS TO PASS B. ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY ARAMBULA
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
INCLUSIVE COLLEGE PILOT PROGRAMS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
NINE FORTY FIVE ARAMBULA FOSTER
CARE IN RICHMOND ACTIVITIES
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
SIXTEEN POWER K. HAND
DIESELISATION FEASIBILITY STUDY
DO PASSES A MINUTE TO MAKE THE
STUDY SUBJECT TO AN
APPROPRIATION REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY EIGHTY NINE OF
OUR QUE HAN PRIVACY MENTAL
HEALTH APPS PRIVACY DO PASS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
ONE OH THREE BAUER K. HAND
CRISIS RESPONSE FROM WHERE
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE PILOT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SIX POWER QUE HAN PESTICIDES TO
PASS. B. ROKE THE ROLL CALL AB.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO BY OUR QUE
HAN HATE CRIMES TO PASS THIS IS
A MINISTER. OFF MEN'S ADD INTENT
LANGUAGE CLARIFYING THIS BILL
DOES NOT PUNISH THE DISPLAY OF
ANY OTHER SPECIFIED RELIGIOUS
SYMBOLS. NOT REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
SIX POWER K. HAND DEATH
CERTIFICATES CONTENT DO PASS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY ONE BAUER K.
HAND FAR ARMS DO PASS B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
BAUER K. HAND CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MEMBER
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING TO
PASS B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT BAUER K. HAND
URINALS ELECTRONIC MONITORING DO
PASS B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH FIVE OUR QUE HAN
ADVANCEMENT MITIGATION AND
REGIONAL CONVERT CONSTRUCT
CONSERVATION INVESTMENT
STRATEGIES TO PASS REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
NINE BENNETT FIREARMS PROHIBITED
PLACS DO PASS B. ROLL CALL. AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE BENNETT.
ON NON MOTORIZED RECREATIONAL
TRAILS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELETE THE APPROPRIATIONS THE
PROPOSED COMMISSION AND THE
GRANT PROGRAMS AND INSTEAD MOVE
THE POWERS AND DUTIES. OF THE
PROPOSED COMMISSION TO THE
EXISTING STATE PARK AND
RECREATION COMMISSION
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE BENNETT
COURT FEE WAIVER WATER RIGHTS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
TWENTY THREE BENNETT GELS THIS
DISCHARGE PLANS TO PASS A
RECALL. A ROLL CALL. I AB TWENTY
TWO OH ONE BENNETT GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTION PERMIT VERIFICATION
DO PASSED B. ROLL CALL A. B.
TWENTY FOUR OH THREE BENNETT CAL
FOR A STUDY HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY FIVE TEN BENNETT
VEHICLES DRIVERS LICENSE TO PASS
A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY TWO BENNETT SCOPING PLAN
REPORTS DO PASS B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO BENNETT
WHEN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
HYDROGEN FOOD FUELING STATIONS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY NINE BENNETT INTENSIVE
FAMILY FINDING. YOU PASS A WERE
A ROLL CALL. AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
THREE BERMAN COMPUTER SCIENCE UP
PRE SERVICE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWO
TWENTY OH SIX BERMAN HOUSING
COMPLIANCE MONITORING TO PASS A
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
NINE BERMAN FOSTER USE SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS DO PASSES A MINUTE
TO MAKE THE BILL CONTINGENT
UPON. AN APPROPRIATION. NOT
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY FOUR BERMAN
RECALL ELECTIONS DO PASSES
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT PER STUDENT
SPENDING BE INCLUDED ON THE
PETITION B. ROLL CALL AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY SIX BERMAN HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONS GRANT PROGRAMS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY FIVE BERMAN CYBERSECURITY
REGIONAL ALLIANCE AND MULTI
STAKEHOLDER PARTNERSHIP PILOT
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTEEN BERMAN
ELECTIONS VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT
DROP OFF LOCATIONS TO PASS B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY
BERMAN SAID S. A. R. T. START
ADVISORY COUNCIL HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE BERMAN PRIORITY
ENROLLMENT FOR STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN TO PASS A
ROLL CALL AB.
TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY.
MMHM THE FALSE REPORTING
PLATFORM DO PASSES A MINUTE WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO
PRODUCTS WITH INTENTIONALLY
ADDED THE FOSS AND EXTEND THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND REPORTING
DEADLINES BY ONE YEAR. AB TWENTY
TWO OF SOARED B. ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FOUR BLOOM
PEDESTRIAN CROSSING SIGNALS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO APPLY TO
STATE SIGNALS ONLY REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN BLOOM WATER JUDGES. YOU
PASS. A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE BLOOM DMV FIELD
OFFICES HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY FIVE TWELVE BLOOM TRANCE
IMPORTANT TRANSPORTATION AND THE
CHILDREN OF ANIMALS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
THREE BLOOM COOLING STATIONS DO
PASSES A MINUTE TO STRIKE OUT
THE SUBSTANTIAL SUBSTANDARD
PROVISIONS. AB TWENTY SIX SORRY. ZERO THE TWENTY FIVE NINETY. A
BLOOM AT TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SEVEN B. ROLL CALL. TWENTY SIX
THIRTY EIGHT BLOOM SCHOOL WATER
BOTTLE FILLING STATIONS TO PASS
A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY ONE BLOOM SURE SERVICE OF
PROCESS AND NOTICE. NOTICES TO
PASS A ROLL CALL A. B. SEVENTEEN
OH SEVEN BORDER HARD RIGHT
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT FUND
DO PASS A ROLL CALL A. B.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BOERNER HORVATH K. TWELVE VISUAL
AND PERFORMING ARTS AND WORLD
LANGUAGES AND STE INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS DO PASS A ROLL CALL.
SEVENTY AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY A.
BOERNER HORVATH EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS TO PASS B. ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY TWO OH FOUR BORDER
HOWEVER AT OFFICE OF CLEAN
ENERGY WORKFORCE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THE OFFICE INSTRUCTORS CREATION
OF THE BOARD B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
BOERNER HORVATH OIL AND GAS
LEASES COST STUDY TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION. ALL
REPUBLICANS. GIVE ME REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY BRIAN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
COMMISSION HOLDEN COMMITTEE A.
B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BRIAN
HOMELESS PARKING VIOLATION
FORGIVENESS TO PASS. A ROLL CALL
. AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY SIX BRIAN
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES
ENFORCEMENT DO PASS B. ROLL CALL
A. B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE
BRIAN FOSTER CARE PRIMARY
LANGUAGES. DO PASS. A ROLL CALL
A. B. C. EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN BRIAN
REENTRY HOUSING AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM DO PASS THE
ROLL CALL. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY ONE
BRIAN FOSTER YOUTH HIRING CREDIT
HOLDING COMMITTEE A. B. NINETEEN
THIRTEEN BRIAN CALIFORNIA CENTER
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY ONE
FIFTY NINE BRIAN REUNIFICATION
SERVICES TO PASS B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETEEN BRIAN
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOBS ACT JUSTICE
FORTY OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE DO
PASSES AMENDED TO CONSOLIDATE
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
CHANGE THE ROLE OF JUSTICE FORTY
COMMITTEE FROM AN OVERSIGHT GOOD
ADVISORY BODY AND MAKE OTHER
CHANGES B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE BRIAN HIGHER UP
FROM CORRECTIONS TO CAREER PILOT
PROGRAMS TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO
BROADEN ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
PROGRAM REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR BRIAN
SUPERVISED SURVIVOR SUPPORT AND
HARM PREVENTION PILOT PROGRAM
ACT HOLDING COMMITTEE. A. B. TWO
ZERO SEVEN SEVEN CALDERON MEDIC
CAL PERSONNEL NEEDS ALLOWANCE TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY ONE CALDERON URBAN
FORESTRY STATE WIDE STRATEGIC
PLAN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELETE THE DEPARTMENT'S
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE.
SPECIFIED INFORMATION. PUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
TWO CALDERON I HSS NEEDS
ASSESSMENT HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY ONE CALDERON
ADULT DAY SERVICES FACILITIES TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY SIX CALDERON SCHOOL
GREENING PROJECTS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY ONE
CALDERON FINANCING ORDERS ONLY
I'M COSTS HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN REAL GOODS
MOVEMENT DATA DO PASS B. ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY FIFTY NINE
CARRILLO HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
BUSINESS AN AREA PLANS TO PASS
NOT REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED CARILLO
CALFRESH RESTAURANTS MILLS
PROGRAM DO PASSED A ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE CARILLO
NET ENERGY METERING AND
PREVAILING WAGES DO PASS. B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX CARILLO DENTAL ASSISTANTS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY FIVE
A ONE CARILLO CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL AFTER SCHOOL WORK
GROUP TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH AND RESEARCH AND MAKE
CONTINGENT. ON AN APPROPRIATION
. PUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTY FIVE CARRILLO CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM RACIAL
DISPARITIES TO PASS WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS EPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY
ONE CERVANTES ELECTIONS.
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
TWO CERVANTES POLITICAL REFORM
ACT NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
REMAINS TO ALLOW FOR EMAIL
FILING REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX-
VONTAZE CALIFORNIA MAINSTREET
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE CERVANTES
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
STUDENTS HOUSING INFORMATION TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
HOUSING INFORMATION TO BE POSTED
EVERY TWO WEEKS REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. A. B. TWENTY FOUR NINETY
ONE CERVANTES POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION COST OF ATTENDANCE
DISCLOSURE HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FIVE OH TWO CERVANTES
FOSTER CARE STATES OF EMERGENCY
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY NINE
CERVANTES HIGH OCCUPANCY VEHICLE
LANES COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE TO
PASS A ROLL CALL A. B. C.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHT CHEN
CALFRESH INCOME ELIGIBILITY DO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE CHILD. CHOI I'M
SORRY. A TEACHER EXPENSES TAX
DEDUCTIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE. THE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX COOLEY
ADMINISTRATIVE REGULATIONS
REVIEW HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT COOLEY
DISCOUNTED PARKS ADMISSION TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ZERO
SIX COOLEY FOSTER CARE NEW
LICENSE TYPE DO PASSES A MINUTE
TO RETAIN ONLY THE I. L. P.
PROVISIONS REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
THREE COOLEY PROTECTION OF PARK
LANDS REMOVAL OF UNPERMITTED
CAMPERS AND CAMP SITES TO PASS
AS A MINUTE TO LIMIT THE BILL TO
THE AMERICAN RIVER PARKWAY IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY REQUIRE THE
GOVERNING BODY TO UTILIZE IT
TRAUMA INFORMED AND HARM
REDUCTION APPROACH. WHEN
REMOVING UNPERMITTED CAMPERS AND
REQUIRE THE COUNTY TO UTILIZE
ALL AVAILABLE FUNDING AND
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
HOUSING AND SERVICES TO DISPLACE
CAMPERS REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETEEN COOLEY
RURAL CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE
ACT HOLDING COMMITTEE A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN COOPER STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
ADMINISTRATION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SPECIFY CERTAIN
RECOVERABLE OVER PAYMENTS AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN COOPER BITING
INTO BINDING ARBITRATION DO PASS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING A. B.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO COOPER
INDUSTRIAL DISABILITY RETIREMENT
DUE PASS. A ROLL CALL OUT ON A-
TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT COOPER
CALIFORNIA PILOT- PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
SIX COOPER INCARCERATED PERSONS
HEALTH RECORDS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE
COOPER CANNABIS CONTROL APPEALS
PANEL MEMBERSHIP CANNABIS TAX
FUND SPENDING REPORTS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE ADDITIONAL
PANEL MEMBERS. B. OUT ON B.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I'M SORRY AB TWENTY
FIFTY ONE CUNNINGHAM FINANCIAL
LITERACY INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVEN A CUNNINGHAM CARBON
CAPTURE UTILIZATION
SEQUESTRATION DO PASSES AMENDED
TO REMOVE FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS A ON A- AB TWENTY
SEVEN ANYONE CUTTING HIM OFF AS
A DIGITAL INNOVATION TO PASS A.
B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR
DOLLY. MORE A MEGAN DOLLY RURAL
EDUCATION TASK FORCE I'M SORRY.
OKAY ON- TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY ONE
CUNNINGHAM TO PASS. A ROLL CALL
. AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS RURAL EDUCATION
TASK FORCE HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR TRANSPORTATION
UNDERSERVED RURAL COMMUNITIES
STUDY. DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
INTEGRATE STUDY WITH LARGE STATE
HIGHWAY PLANNING PROCESSES IT'S
A ROLL CALL. AB SIXTEEN ANYONE
DALY INSURANCE FUND PREVENTION
TO PASS A ROLL CALL A. B.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE DALY COVER
NINETEEN WORKERS COMPENSATION TO
PASS B. ROLL CALL AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY ONE DALY TO ADDRESS
CONFIDENTIALITY HOLDEN COMMITTEE
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY DALY.
UNEMPLOYMENT FUND APPROPRIATION
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY THREE DAILY
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT TO
PASS. A ROLL CALL. AB SIXTEEN
ELEVEN DAVIES OIL SPILLS
REPORTING TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE DAVIS
CALIFORNIA STATE APPROVING
AGENCY FOR VETERANS EDUCATION
REGULATIONS TO PASS A ROLL CALL
THEY BEAT SEVENTEEN FIFTY DAVIS
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY FOUR OH NINE
DAVIES PAROLE HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY NINE DAVIS
HEALTH CARE WHAT MIDWIFE
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. AB EIGHTEEN NINETY TWO
FLOOR MEDIKAL ORTHOPEDICS AND
PROSTHETICS TO PASS A ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY SEVENTY EIGHT FLORA OF
MISHEARD RIVERS PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN FLOOR VETERANS MEDICAL
FOSTER HOME PILOT PROGRAM TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SIX FOR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY TWO FLOOR
STATEWIDE DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
PLATFORM HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY OH THREE MIKE FONG MODEL
CAREER PATHWAYS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL.
THEY WILL CONTINUE A. B. TWENTY
TWO FIFTY FIVE MIKE FONG THE
AFFORDABLE BROADBAND SERVICE
PROGRAM FOR CALIFORNIA DREAMERS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT VINCE FONG BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION HOLDING
COMMITTEE A. B. SIXTEEN SEVENTY
NINE VINCE FONG SUPPLY CHAIN
ADVISOR HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE VINCE FONG
BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE INCE FONG MOTORCYCLE
LICENSING PILOT PROGRAM TO PASS
WITH AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
DMB TO CONDUCT INSPECTIONS AND
MAINTAIN CHP AUTHORITY A ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY FIVE OH NINE-VINCE FONG VEHICLES REGISTRATION
FEES EXEMPTIONS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT VINCE FONG VETERANS
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION COMMITTEE
A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY THREE.
FRIEDMAN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WELFARE EXEMPTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE CONSTRUCTION
TO BEGIN WITHIN FIVE YEARS AND
CLARIFY AUDIT PROVISIONS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT FRIEDMAN
TRANSIT AND INTERCITY RAIL
RECOVERY TASK FORCE TO PASS. A
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR FRIEDMAN HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING TO
PASS B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
TWENTY SIX FRIEDMAN PLASTIC
PACKAGING AND CARRY OUT BACK TO
PASS AS AMENDED WITH AUTHORED
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE A CLEAR
FIND DEFINITION EXEMPT THE LIFE
SCIENCES INDUSTRY AND ELIMINATE
THE ROOT REINCE REINSTATEMENT OF
THE APPS STORE RECYCLING
PROGRAM. THAT'S OUT WITH THE B.
ROLL CALL. TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE FRIEDMAN. FOSTER USE
DOCUMENTS TO PASS WITH COLOR
FINE AMENDMENTS REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
SEVEN FRIEDMAN TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND CLIMATE GOALS TO
PASS WITH AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO
ALIGN. REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
TWENTY THREE OH NINE FRIEDMAN
GUARDIANSHIP TO PASS THE ROLL
CALL A. B. TWENTY THREE THIRTY
SIX. FRIEDMAN SPEED SAFETY
SYSTEM HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FOUR FRIEDMAN
WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO PASS
IS A MINUTE WITH AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS TO DELETE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CDFW TO AND
THEN IF I AREAS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO WILDLIFE MOVEMENT
TO LEAD THE REQUIREMENT FOR
CALTRANS TO IMPLEMENTED AT LEAST
TEN PROJECTS PER YEAR. AND MAKE
CALTRANS PROB PROGRAMMATIC
REVIEW PERMISSIVE. THE ROLL CALL.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TURN BACK VERY
QUICKLY THE AB TWENTY THREE OH
NINE FRIEDMAN GUARDIANSHIP IT'S
A DO PASS. WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT FRIEDMAN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING ALIGNMENT AND WITH STATE
PLANS IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS STANDARDS
TO PASS. OUT OF THE B. ROLL CALL
. AB TWENTY SIX TEN FRIEDMAN
ECOLOGICAL SENSITIVE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY SEVEN FRIEDMAN
INTEGRATED DISTRICT DISTRICT
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
FUND TO PASS OUT ON A BUSY. AB
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX FRIEDMAN
DRIVING PRIVILEGES SUSPENSION TO
PASS AS A MINUTE TO DELAY
EFFECTIVE DATE UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN NOT ON THE B. ROLL
CALL A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY FOUR
GABRIEL NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT
PROGRAM TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
NARAL PROGRAM EXPANSION.
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
NINETEEN ELEVEN GABRIEL HOUSING
PRESERVE PRESERVATION TAX CREDIT
HOLDING COMMITTEE A. B. NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE GABRIEL MEDICO
VIOLENCE. VIOLENCE PREVENTION
SERVICES TO PASS THE ROLL CALL
A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY ONE GABRIEL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ONLINE
DATABASE TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB.
TWENTY SEVENTY TWO GABRIEL
SCHOOL DISTRICT MENTAL HEALTH.
PERSONNEL SHARING AGREEMENTS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY TWO GABRIEL TURF
REPLACEMENT INCLUSION EXCLUSION
DO PASS A- AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FOUR GABRIEL DIGITAL LITERACY
LITERACY AND MEDIA LITERACY
GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY THREE FORTY SIX
GABRIEL OUTDOORS FOR ALL PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY SIX GABRIEL OFFICE
FOR THE PROTECTION OF CHILDREN
ONLINE HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY GABRIEL
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO PASS AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN. I'M
SORRY. PUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN GABRIEL
INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN YOU
PASSES AMENDED TO REMOVE LOCAL
AGENCIES FROM THE BILL AND ADD
LEGISLATIVE INTENT REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
TWO GABRIEL NON U. S. VETERAN.
RESIGNATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX GALLAGHER
PROP PAYMENT ACT TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY THREE
GALLAGHER PG&E REVIEWED TO PASS
A ROLL CALL A. B. SEVENTEEN
FORTY NINE GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
BLUEPRINT TO PASS AS AMENDED
WITH AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO MODIFY
THE PERMIT POSTING REQUIREMENTS
B. ROLL CALL. A. B. SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA CALIFORNIA HEALTHY PLACES
INDEX TO PASS B. ROLL CALL AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN CRISTINA
GARCIA SOLID WASTE DIVERSION
CREDIT TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELETE THE CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. BEFORE CAL RECYCLE
CAN APPROVED SPECIFIED PERMITS
B. ROLL CALL AB NINETEEN TEN
CRISTINA GARCIA GOLF COURSES
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA PEOPLE SUPPORT TRAINING
PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN CRISTINA
GARCIA CHARTER SCHOOL OF SCHOOL
SITE ACQUISITION DO PASS B. ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
CRISTINA GARCIA REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE PILOT PROGRAM DO
PASSED B. ROLL CALL A. B. TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FOUR CRISTINA GARCIA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEE PAID PARENTAL LEAVE OF
ABSENCE DUE PASSED B. ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX CHRIS
GARCIA REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL
HEALTH INEQUITIES DO PASSED B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
NINE CRISTINA GARCIA NATURAL
CARBON SEQUESTRATION AND
RESILIENCE ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
TO DO PASSED B. ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN
CRISTINA GARCIA VEHICLES.
DISABLED VETERANS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY
FIVE EDUARDO GARCIA SUBSTITUTE
EDUCATORS SUPPORT GRANT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
THIRTY TWO EDUARDO GARCIA AND
THE MILITARY AND VETERAN SUICIDE
TASK FORCE TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
AB TWENTY FORTY ONE EDWARD
GARCIA PRIMARY DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA. CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE
SPECIAL EDUCATION RESOURCE LOOP
LEADS. TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA G. R. F. A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN CONTINUOUS
APPROPIATION TO PASS. THE ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY TWO FORTY THREE
EDUARDO GARCIA OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MODIFY THE
SCOPE. OF REVISED STANDARDS B.
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SIX EDUARDO GARCIA CALIFORNIA
MEXICO CROSS BORDER RIVERS
FUNDING TO PASS A RICK ROLL CALL
. AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY THREE
EDUARDO GARCIA ADAPTIVE SPORTS
HUB'S PILOT PROGRAM FOLDING
COMMITTEE. A. B. TWENTY THREE
SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA SAFE
DRINKING WATER WHILE FIRE
PREVENTION DROUGHT PER
PREPARATION FLOOD PROTECTION
EXTREME HEAT MITIGATION AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOND
ACTIVE TWENTY THAT'S A HECK OF A
LONG TIME. THAT'S NOT THE REASON
WHY FILLING COMMITTEE BUT IT'LL
COMMITTEE. WHAT. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FIVE EDUARDO GARCIA
DISABILITY ACCESS AND
PLAYGROUNDS TO PASS A ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
EDUARDO GARCIA ENERGY FIRM
RENEWABLE ENERGY RESOURCES AND
FIRM ZERO CARBON RESOURCES
PROCUREMENT TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REMOVE CQC'S CONSIDERATION
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
SIX OH ONE EDUARDO GARCIA
LANDFILLS MEXICO BORDER HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
SIX OR WHATEVER SEE ELECTRICITY
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES STATE POLICY
TRANSMISSION PLANNING TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE CQC
REQUIREMENTS B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA AFFORDABLE INTERNET AND
THAT EQUITY ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
TO DO PASSED B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA CAR MORE YOUR MORAL AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS ATTAINMENT
PROGRAM VEHICLE REGISTRATION
FEES CALIFORNIA TIRE FEE DO
PASSES A MINUTE WITH AUTHOR
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. AND TO
EXTEND DATE THE TWENTY THIRTY
FOUR REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN EDUARDO
GARCIA EXCLUDED WORKERS PILOT
PROGRAM TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND MAKE THE
BILL CONTINGENT. ON
APPROPRIATION B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY ONE EDUARDO
GARCIA SALTON SEA GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCE AREA LITHIUM VALLEY
OFFICE THE DEVELOPMENT HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA SAFER.
PROGRAM TRIBES TO PASS A ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA SALES TAX
EXCLUSION PROGRAM TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. AB TWENTY NINE OH THREE
EDUARDO GARCIA EQUITABLE ACCESS
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY NINE AM WHERE
GARCIA LITHIUM PRODUCTION REPORT
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. A. B. SIXTEEN
TWENTY ONE GIPSON FIRE ARMS
UNSERE REALIZE FIRE ARMS TO PASS
B. ROLL CALL. AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
TWO GIPSON PROFESSIONAL
LICENSOR. APRI APPLICATION DO
PASSED B. ROLL CALL AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY FOUR GIPSON. POSTED
OPTION CONTACT AGREEMENTS TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR GIPSON CRIMINAL LAW
CERTIFICATE A REHABILITATION TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
MEN'S. THE RESTORE EXISTING LAW
RELATED TO SPECIFIC CRIMINAL.
DEFENDANTS B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR GIPSON MICRO
MOBILITY. DEVICES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
NINE GIPSON CRIMINAL PROCEDURES
TO PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
TO THIRTY GIPSON CAL WORKS
HOUSING BENEFITS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO RESTORE THE TWELVE
MONTH LIMIT. ZERO CALL AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX GIPSON MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN GIPSON
VEHICLES DRIVER EDUCATION TO
PASS. A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY
SEVEN OH TO GIPSON CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICE FUND BROADBAND
PUBLIC HOUSING ACCOUNT TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY FOUR GIPSON SCHOOL
CLIMATE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
AND TRAINING MATERIALS TO PASS
B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY A GRAY CHARLES. JAMES
OVERSTREET JUNIOR COURTHOUSE TO
PASS B. ROLL CALL AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO GRAY PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM
TO PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY TWO GRAY VEHICLES
CATALYTIC CONVERTERS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
GRAY COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDIT HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY ONE. GRAYSON
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TRAINING
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE A. B.
NINETEEN OH FOUR GRAYSON
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS SOLICITATION
DISCLOSURE DO PASSED AS AMENDED
TO CLARIFY THE DEFINITION. OF
COVERED PERSON REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING A. B. NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
GRAYSON MANUFACTURING SALES TAX
EXEMPTION TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO
REINSTATE THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION CAP. REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AB TWO A TWENTY OH ONE
GRAYSON REMOTE WORK FOR LENDERS
TO PASSED. OUT ON A- I AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY SIX GRAYSON FREE
REDUCTION INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB TWENTY THREE
OH FIVE GRAYSON COORDINATED
HOUSING FINANCIAL COMMITTEE DO
PASSES AMENDED. TO CLARIFY THE
CAL EIGHT HFA PROVISIONS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY GRAYSON ZERO MISSION
AFTER MARKET CONVERSION TO PASS.
A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY THREE GRAYSON MAST. MA
ESTY DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
ACCEPT AUTHOR MEN'S TO MOVE THE
PROGRAM TO THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWO GRAYSON GREENHOUSE
GASES WORK FROM HOME OPTION
HOLDING COMMITTEE SB SIX YOU
KNOW FOR HOLDEN UPWARD MOBILITY
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TO DO PASS.
B. ROLL CALL AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
HOLDING COMMUNITY CARE
FACILITIES CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS TO PASS B. ROLL CALL. AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN HOLDEN
CHILDREN'S CAMPS LOCAL
REGISTRATION INSPECTIONS MEMBERS
REMOVE REQUIRED INSPECTIONS.
AMONG OTHER THINGS. B. ROLL CALL
AB NINETEEN NINETEEN HOLDEN
YOUTH TRANSIT PASS PILOT PROGRAM
TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO MAKE THE
PROGRAM AN OPT IN PROGRAM INTO
ALLOCATE FUNDS. IN PROPORTION TO
STATE FAREBOX REVENUE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY SIX HOLDEN
EMBODIED CARBON EMISSIONS
CONSTRUCTION MATERIALS TO PASS
THE ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTEEN HOLDEN SECURITY SERVICES
DO PASSED WITH CAR FIND
AMENDMENTS A ROLL CALL UP SORRY
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING- AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTEEN HOLDING
COLLEGE AND CAREER ACCESS
PATHWAYS PARTNERSHIP EXPANSION
TO PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY TWO HOLDEN SEGREGATED
CONFINEMENT TO PASS. ZERO CALL
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR HOLDING
JUVENILES CUSTODY- ENTERED
INTERROGATION TO PASS AS AMENDED%
TO ACCEPT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY DEFINITION AND MOVE THE
LANGUAGE TO THE PENAL CODE. B.
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT HOLDEN TELECOMMUNICATIONS
DIGITAL EQUITY AND VIDEO
FRANCHISE ENACTED TWENTY TWENTY
TO DO PASSED THE ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY THREE
HOLDEN TRAFFIC OR PEDESTRIAN
STOPS NOTIFICATION BY PEACE
OFFICERS DO PASSES A MINUTE TO
ACCEPT AUTHOR MEN'S TO REMOVE
THE FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT POINT
FIVE REMEDY. THE ROLL CALL. AB
SEVENTEEN OH FIVE- WINS SEE MORE
CAMPBELL STUDENT SUCCESS ACT OF
TWENTY TWELVE TO PASS A ROLL
CALL A. B. C. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
THREE IRWIN. READY RETURN TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE BILL
PROVISIONS AND INSTEAD REQUIRE
F. T. B. TO NOTIFY CAL. FIRES
EILERS. OF EXISTING PAPERLESS
FILING OPTIONS B. ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY SIXTY FOUR IRWIN MEDIA
LITERACY HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY FIVE IRWIN
INFORMATIONAL SECURITY DO PASSED
A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN OR ONE ST
SERVICING SURFING RESERVES
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY IRWIN OFFICE OF
INFORMATION SECURITY TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
SIX IRWIN CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION RECEIPT OF DONATIONS
AND- PHILANTHROPIC FUNDS TO PASS
A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT OR ONE EMPLOYEES
WITH DISABILITIES HIRING CREDIT
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY IRWIN RESPONSIBLE
RESPONSIBLE BATTERY RECYCLING
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO DO
PASSED B. ROLL CALL AB TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY THREE IRWIN. AUSPICE
LICENSOR MORATORIUM ON NEW
LICENSES TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY NINE IRWIN
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS WINE AND
DISTILLED SPIRITS TO PASS A ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
THREE IRWIN CO IN NINETEEN
TESTING CAPACITY TO PASS A ROLL
CALL FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FIFTY FIVE
JONES SAWYER JUNETEENTH HOLIDAY
DO PASSES A MINUTE TO MODIFY
COMMEMORATION OF THE HOLIDAY
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
EIGHTEEN OH THREE JOHN SURE
SAWYER PROBATION ABILITY TO PAY
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT
AUTHOR REMAINS TO ALLOW LOW
INCOME PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR RELIEF B. ROLL CALL AB
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY ONE JONES
SAWYER CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE JONES SAWYER BELL
BONDS. DO PASSES AMENDED TO MAKE
. THE PAST AS AMENDED TO AMONG
OTHER THINGS DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE
JONES SAWYER SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
PERSONNEL COMMISSIONS DO PASS. A
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
FOUR JONES SAWYER DIVERSION FOR
REPEAT RETAIL THEFT CRIMES TO
PASS. A REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY SIX JONES
SAWYER TASK FORCE TO STUDY AND
DEVELOP REPARATION PROPOSALS FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS TO PASS. THE
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY ONE CHOICE OR YOUR
CUBANOS ROOM CONFINEMENT DO
PASSES A MINUTE TO ALLOW FOR TWO
HOURS OF BRIEF CONFINEMENT
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY THREE JONES SAWYER.
RENTAL HOUSING APPLICATIONS TO
PASS B. ROLL CALL AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY FOUR JONES SAWYER PUBLIC
ON TRACK PROTEST TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THERE WERE
PROTESTS OPTION REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE JONES OR DIVERSITY AND
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES TO PASS B.
OUT ON A BE. A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE KALRA CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS ANIMALS
VETERINARY MEDICINE DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO EXCLUDE. WOOD ANIMALS
AND LIVESTOCK TO AVOID CDF
HAVING TO EVALUATE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FOR HORSES. REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING AB TWENTY NINETY FIVE
KALRA WORKER METRICS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT POWER- DIVERSITY IN
CONSERVATION REPORT DO PASS. THE
ROLL CALL I'M SORRY A. TWENTY
KALRA TWENTY TO SEVENTY A DO
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED KALRA CALL WORKS
IN CALFRESH WORK REQUIREMENTS TO
PASS AS A MINUTE TO RETAIN ONLY
THE LABOR PROVISIONS. B. ROLL
CALL AB TWENTY FOUR EIGHTEEN
KALRA CRIMINAL CRIMES JUSTICE
DATA ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY ACT. DO PASS BE OR
CALL. MAYBE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FOUR KALRA SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY DO PASS
B. ROLL CALL AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY FOUR COVER PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION COSTS OF
COURSE MATERIALS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE- AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
FOUR KALRA CANNABIS CATERING
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR KILEY NOTARIES
PUBLIC CERTIFICATE CORRECTIONS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN LACKEY DATA
COLLECTION HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY LACK A CANNABIS
RESEARCH DRIVING SAFETY DO
PASSED AS AMENDED. TO CHANGE THE
DISBURSEMENT TO A ONE TIME
DISBURSEMENT CLARIFY INTENT A
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
ONE LACKEY EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FOUR LACKEY GABRIEL'S LAW
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN LEE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
HOLDING COMMITTEE. A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN LEE SCHOOL
FACILITIES MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS BATHROOMS TO PASS A
ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE LEAD JURY DUTY DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS TO INCLUDE ALAMEDA
COUNTY REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
TWENTY FIFTY THREE LEAST SOCIAL
HOUSING ACT TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO CHANGE LANGUAGE RELATED TO
REQUIRED LABOR STANDARDS TO
EXPRESS. LEGISLATIVE INTENT.
THAT'S OUT ON BE. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR LEE DISABILITY ACCESS
FUNDING DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE CERTAIN REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
TWO LEE LIGHT POLLUTION TO PASS.
A RECALL AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
NINE LEAVE VEHICLES TOLL
EXEMPTION DO PASS A RECALL. A.
B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE LEVINE
LOBBYING ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIONS
TO PASS A ROLL CALL AB EIGHTEEN
TEN LEVINE PUPIL SEIZURE
DISORDERS TO PASS A ROLL CALL A.
B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE LEVINE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO PASS
A. B. ROLL CALL. AB NINETEEN
SEVENTEEN LEVINE CONTRACTING
TRACING CONTACT TRACING TO PASS
B. ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY TWO. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY LEVINE PUBLIC RECORDS
STATE AGENCY RETENTION DO PASS A
ROLL CALL AB TWENTY SEVEN OH SIX
LEVINE. INNOCENCE COMMISSION
PILOT PROGRAMS HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY THREE
LEVINE MEDIKAL HOME UPKEEP
ALLOWANCE AND TRUE TRANSITIONAL
NEEDS ALLOWANCE TO PASS A- AB
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED LOW BONE MARROW
AND BLOOD STEM CELL REGISTRY DO
PASSES A MINUTE TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION TO TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. A ROLL CALL AB EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO LOW ELECTIONS DAY
HOLIDAY HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
NINETEEN FORTY LOW BEREAVEMENT
LEAVE TO PASS OUT ON A BE. AB
TWENTY FIFTY FIVE LOW CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE CURES DATABASE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SIX LOW LUNAR NEW YEAR HOLIDAY
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO MODIFY
COMMEMORATION OF THE HOLIDAY.
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
SIX SIXTEEN LOW CONSERVATORSHIP
AND GUARDIANSHIP HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE LOW. CERTIFIED ACCESS
SPECIALISTS GRANTS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
ONE LOW DISQUALIFICATION FROM
VOTING TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO
MAKE A TECHNICAL CHANGE RELATED
TO FIRST CLASS MAIL. OUT ON B.
A. B. NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT MIKE
FONG COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
DEBT CANCELLATION PROGRAM TO
PASS THAT'S ON A- OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. THOSE. AS YOU CAN TELL
THAT WHEN WAS OUT OF ORDER. BUT
IT'S IN ORDER AND YOU KNOW. IT'S
AN ORDER BUT IT'S. OKAY OH I'M
SORRY. THE. OKAY MAYBE SIXTEEN
FORTY EIGHT MAIENSCHEIN ANIMAL
EVACUATION PLAN. A DEEP PASSES A
MINUTE TO STRIKE EVACUATION PLAN
DETAILS REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY THRE
MAIENSCHEIN PROTECTIVE PROCEEDED
PROCEEDINGS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ACCEPT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS TO
MOVE CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES AND REDUCE THE
APPROPRIATION REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING SIXTEEN NINETY EIGHT
MAIENSCHEIN PACKAGE STUFF HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
MAIENSCHEIN DAFT ONLINE
MARKETPLACE REPORTING TO PASS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING A. B.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SIX MAIENSCHEIN
PEACE OFFICERS MENTAL HEALTH TO
PASS. THAT'S OUT ON A- A. B. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE MAIENSCHEIN
WATER BOTTLE REFILL STATIONS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. THE TWENTY
FORTY MAIENSCHEIN CRIMINAL
PROCEDURES HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY NINE
MAIENSCHEIN FIREARMS PROHIBITED
PERSONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ACCEPT AUTHOR MEN'S ELIMINATE
RETROACTIVITY REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
ALL META. CAL YOU PASSED OUT ON
A- AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE
MAIENSCHEIN ORGANIC TRANSITION
PILOT PROGRAM TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REVISE PROGRAM MINISTRATION
WITHIN CDFA. THAT'S ON THE B. AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY MAIENSCHEIN
CELL DEATH INVESTIGATIONS REVIEW
TEAM TO PASS THAT'S A- A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVEN NINE MATHIS WATER
BOARDS AND FOUND FOUNDED OR
FRIVOLOUS COMPLAINTS TO PASS ON
A- A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE.
MATHIS ALSO PERSON OF THE PERSON
NAY SEND YOU PASS THAT'S ON A-
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX MATHIS
WOODY BIOMASS COLLECTION PROGRAM
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
NINETY THREE MATHIS FIRST
RESPONDER LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY. TWO NINETY EIGHT MAYES
RECREATIONAL WATER USE WAVE
BASINS TO PASS THAT'S OUT ON THE
EIGHT. AB SIXTEEN OH TWO MCCARTY
CALIFORNIA STUDENT HOUSING RIVER
REVOLVING LOAN FUND ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DEEP. PASSES A
MINUTE TO PRESCRIBE PROCEDURES
WERE ESTABLISHED IN A BITTER
POOL OF CONTRACTORS IN REQUIRE
SPECIFIED WORK TO BE PERFORMED
BY UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT MCCARTY
HOPE CALIFORNIA HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTEEN
MCCARTY CALIFORNIA SERVICES
PILOT PROGRAM TO PASS THAT'S ON
A- AB TWENTY TWO OH SEVEN
MCCARTY CALIFORNIA. CONSERVATION
CORPS HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY TWO MCCARTY SCHOOL
AND UNIVERSITY HEATING
VENTILATION AND AIR CONDITIONING
SYSTEMS MAINTENANCE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REQUIRE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THE MAIN KICK
MAINTAINED HVAC SYSTEMS A
SPECIFIED INTO REQUIRED DSA. THE
RESEARCH THE ADOPTION OF CARBON
MONOXIDE MONITORS IN CLASSROOMS
THAT'S GONNA BE. WHEN FOUR AB
TWENTY FOUR ONE MCCARTY TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS PLANNING
GRANTS TO PASS THAT'S A- AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO MCCARTY
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
INVESTMENTS TO PASS THAT'S ON A-
AB TWENTY FOUR. FIFTY SIX
MCCARTY CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
SUMMER TURNS GRANT KOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY FIVE OH
SEVEN MCCARTY THE AFTER SCHOOL
EDUCATION SAFETY PROGRAM IN
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY COMMUNITY
LEARNING CENTERS PROGRAM TO
PASS. THE MEMBERS TWO ONE
SPECIFY OPERATIVE DATE OF THE
BILL TO CLARIFY ALLOCATION OF
FUNDS AND THREE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY-
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
THAT'S REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY TWO MCCARTY
FIREARMS GUN SHOWS AND EVENTS TO
PASSAGE ON THE B. ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY THREE
MCCARTY SCHOOL TEACHER PERMANENT
STATUS TO PASS THAT'S B. ROLL
CALL A. B. TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO
MCCARTY FOODS SUPPORT PILOT
PROGRAM. HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY MCCARTY
CALIFORNIA RICE PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED MCCARTY TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION ELECTRICAL
DISTRIBUTION GRID UPGRADES TO
PASS REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY ONE MCCARTY
DEATHS WHILE AND LAW.
ENFORCEMENT CUSTODY DO PASS
THAT'S A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT MCCARTY
CRIMES RACE BLIND CHARGING TO
PASS A ROLL CALL AB IN SIXTEEN
NINETY ONE MEDINA CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES SUMMER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM TO PASSAS A MINUTE TO
MAKE CONTINGENT. ON AN
APPROPRIATION THAT'S OUT ON THE
B. AB SEVENTEEN OH ONE MEDINA
JUMPSTART GRANT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX MEDINA CAL GRANT REFORM ACT
YOU PASS REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
A. B. SEVENTEEN SIXTY FOUR
MEDINA. COLLEGE UNIVERSITY
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY STUDENT
HOUSING SURVEY DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO STRIKE FIELD ACT
EXEMPTION REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY FOUR MEDINA
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENTS STAFF
AND FACULTY PROTECTION ACT.
FOLDING COMMITTEE. AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY SIX MEDINA PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY HOURS
TO PASS OUT ON A AB TWENTY FORTY
SIX MEDINA AND WHEN RISING FUND
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
CONTINGENT ON AN APPROPRIATION
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
SEVENTEEN OH SIX MAYOR BONTA
CANNABIS CRIMES RESENTENCING TWO
PASSES A MINUTE TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
REMAINS TO AMONG OTHER THINGS
SPECIFIED THAT DOJ MUST REPORT.
ON ITS UPDATE TO THE STATE'S
SUMMARY CRIMINAL HISTORY
DATABASE IN THE JOINT PROGRESS
REPORT. REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVEN MIA
BONTA RESIDENTIAL REAL PROPERTY
TO FORECLOSURE DO PASSES A
MINUTE TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS TO CHANGE THE TRUSTEE
FEE. THAT'S OUT ON THE B. ROLL
CALL IT AB NINETEEN TWELVE MIA
BONTA SCHOOL CLOSURE AND
CONSOLIDATION REQUIREMENTS TO
PASS ITS OWN A- AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY ME A BONTA PRISONERS
REENTRY HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY THREE MIA BONTA
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. A. B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY ONE YEAH BONTA JUVENILES
TRANSFERRED TO COURT OF CRIMINAL
JURISDICTION TO PASS ON THE B.
A. B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
MIA BONTA MUSEUM WELFARE
EXEMPTIONS HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE ME ABOUT
A THIRD GRADE LITERACY GRANT
PROGRAM TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO
MAKE SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTEEN MIA BONTA
CRITICAL TO CAREER. DO YOU PASS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY NINE MIA BONTA STREET
HARASSMENT PREVENTION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
ME A BONTA STAY DIGITAL EQUITY
PLAN TO PASS. THAT'S OUT ON A-
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE MIA
BONTA PROMOTE OWNERSHIP BY
WORKERS OF ECONOMIC WORK. FOR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY ACT THE PAST
IS AMENDED TO MODIFY THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
ASSOCIATION OF CORPORATE LABOR
CONTRACTORS IN MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATIONS. AND STRIKE THE
TAX EXEMPTION THAT'S OUT ON THE
B. AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT EMAIL
BONTA COLLEGE ACCESS TAX CREDIT
PASS. THIS ON A WHIM AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY ONE MULLIN CHILD
DAYCARE FACILITIES TO PASS SETS
OUT ON A- A. B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO MULLIN ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT. THE OFFICIAL PROJECTS
INTERAGENCY COORDINATION DO
PASSES A MINUTE WITH AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW THE STATE
WATER. BOARD TO ACCEPT DONATIONS
AND GRANTS ON BEHALF OF ITSELF
AND REGIONAL WATER BOARDS. FOR
SPECIFIED PURPOSES REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
THREE MULLIN. HE'S OFFICER
TRAINING HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY. TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWO MULLIN TRANSIT BUS
SALES TAX EXEMPTION DO PASSED
OUT ON A- A. B. NINETEEN FORTY
TWO MURATSUCHI COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND STRICT
INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICES
AGREEMENTS WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES DO PASS IT'S OUT ON A-
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY MURATSUCHI
ONCE THROUGH COOLING POWER
PLANTS HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY MURATSUCHI
HOMELESS COURT PILOT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY FOUR MURATSUCHI STATE ROAD
SEVEN ONE OH SEVEN.
RELINQUISHMENT DO PASS OUT OF
THE EIGHT. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN MURATSUCHI DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY WILDFIRE.
URNESS AN MITIGATION DO PASS
THAT'S ON A HEY AB TWO SEVEN OH
THREE MURATSUCHI ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS
RELIABILITY STANDARDS LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO PASS
THAT'S ON IT HEY. AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY FIVE MURATSUCHI
HOMELESS DATA HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY THREE
MARKET BASED COMPLIANCE
MECHANISM EVALUATION DO PASS ON
THE B. AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
MURATSUCHI PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION PUBLIC ADVISOR
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB EIGHTEEN
OH ONE THE SYRIAN GENOCIDE
AWARENESS DAY HOLIDAY DO PASSES
A MINUTE TO MODIFY COMMEMORATION
OF THE HOLIDAY. REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AB EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN IS-
AND CULTURAL HERITAGE
DESTRUCTION CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES AND MUSEUMS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN
IS ERIN CORPORATE BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE NAZARIAN
BUS SHELTERS HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY TWO NAZARIAN
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COVERAGE
INFORMATION TO PASS ON A- AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE
MIZORAM SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
COUNSELORS TO PASS THAT'S OUT ON
A A. B. TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX
NAZARIAN. THEY'VE DESIGNATED
SUPPORT PERSONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO RETAIN ONLY THE
WORKING GROUP REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN THE SYRIAN HOUSING
STABILIZATION FOR OLDER ADULTS
TO PASSAGE B. AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY EIGHT NAZARIAN AGING PLACE
NURSING PROGRAM TO PASS THIS
AMENDED TO REDUCE THE PILOT. THE
THREE YEARS THAT'S OUT ON IT A.
B. SEVEN A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN THE SYRIAN TEAM USA
STUDENT ATHLETES DO PASSES OUT
ON A- A. B. SIXTEEN HUNDRED NEW
GRAND CALIFORNIA COMMISSIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. TO RECONFIGURE
THE MEMBERSHIP THAT'S OUT ON A
A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY FIVE GRAND
SUICIDE PREVENTION MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER EDUCATIONAL LOAN
REPAYMENT HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY NINE GRAND
HOMELESS WORKING GROUP HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
OH DONALD LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY
MEDICAL BILLING OPTIONS TO PASS
A AB TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT
O'DONNELL CALIFORNIA CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION INCENTIVE
GRANT PROGRAM IN STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM. DO PASSED.
THAT'S OUT ON A- AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY- DON AIR ISSUE PROGRAM. A
DREDGE VEHICLES HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
O'DONNELL HOMELESS REPORT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MODIFY THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT O'DONNELL LOS
ANGELES OCEAN DUMPSITE DDT DO
PASS SETS OUT ON A- AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY THREE O'DONNELL.
SCHOOL TRANSPORTATION FUNDING TO
PASS IT'S AN EIGHTY. A. B.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR WHISTLE
BLOWER PROTECTION HOLDING
COMMITTEE A. B. SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY THREE PATTERSON
WILLIAMSON ACT PROCREATION HOLD
AND COMMITTEE. AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY ONE PATTERSON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WEBSITE
INFORMATION HOLDING COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY ONE PATTERSON
DISTRACTED DRIVER AWARENESS
GRANT DO PASS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY FIVE
PATTERSON. AND PROGRAM GRANTS TO
PASS THAT'S ON A- AB TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY FIVE PATTERSON
PARENT AND CHILD RELATIONSHIP TO
PASS OUT ON A- AB NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN PETRIE-NORRIS
CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES COURTS TO PASS. THAT'S
OUT ON THE B. A B. TWENTY
NINETEEN PETRIE-NORRIS SMALL AND
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESSES TO
PASS. ON A AB TWENTY EIGHTY
SEVEN PETRIE-NORRIS PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS ADDICTION TREATMENT
FACILITIES HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
23-14 PETRIE-NORRIS SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN PROGRAM TO PASS AS
A MINUTE TO MODIFY THE DEBT
SERVICE COVERAGE RATIO AND
FURTHER SPECIFY THE BILL'S
APPLICATION TO FOR FEDERALLY
FUNDED LOANS REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SIX PETRIE-NORRIS ONE STOCK
CAPITAL PLATFORM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
SIX PETRIE-NORRIS EXHAUST
01: